parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
je t'écris ces quelques lignes pour te
dire que oui je suis prêt à faire un
petit bout de chemin avec toi ps quand
je parle de bout de chemin je veux dire
départ de chez moi arriver au boulot
puis retour mais aussi possible tous les
jours
merci à toi le covoiturage c'est
convivial économique et écologique
avec le covoiturage saint quentin en
yvelines vous propose une nouvelle façon
de vous déplacer
les inscriptions et les infos sur
www.covoiturage.fr au tir et est-ce qu y
point fr
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour ce nouveau numéro d' équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement un numéro
consacré à l'éco consommation dans
lequel nous apprendrons à consommer
autrement grâce au sel ces associations
qui échange des biens des services entre
adhérents mais aussi avec le covoiturage
pour apprendre à nous déplacer
différemment mais tout d'abord qu'est-ce
qui est celle pour répondre nous sommes
avec vous un monique martini bonjour
nouveau dans les locaux de la mare lô
c'est la pagaille est en cours
concrètement qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'un sel alors le sense est un système
d'échangé local c'est-à-dire un échange
de savoirs et de biens entre adhérents
alors vous avez un système de points qui
n'est pas comptabilisée en euros mais en
grenouille à tout à fait c'est une
monnaie virtuelle qui représente environ
1 euro
une grenouille représente à peu près un
nouveau et est déterminé
de gré à gré par les adhérents au moment
des échanges alors un adhérent part au
départ des lags réinscription avec 74
points 75 grenouille ce qui lui permet
de participer dès le départ à des
échanges d'accord et alors qu'elle sous
ces échanges principaux qu'on peut
rencontrer entre adhérents et bien il ya
par exemple les échanges de biens tous
les samedis à la mare au sel chacun
apporte ce qu'il veut échanger et
ensuite vous avez des échanges
informatiques
décollage
le voiture etc
c'est très vaste et l'électricité
absolument il ya un catalogue assez
assez conséquent des savoir faire de
chaque adhérent d'accord et c'est donc
gratuit et chacun dérange c'est vraiment
service
absolument et aucun des changes en grand
en europe avance et comment fonctionne
l'assurance par exemple si en allant
chez un autre adhérent
il y a un souci de la casse ou une
cheville foulée par exemple il ya une
associée une assurance associative qui
est prise par l'association donc qui
couvrent qu'il est tous les risques
inhérents aux échanges
alors l'association a été créée en 1995
elle compte combien d'adhérents
aujourd'hui on nous devons être à peu
près 90
ça les rend actuellement oui alors qui
sous ses adhérents principalement de
tous les univers de tous les univers
depuis le bas jusqu'en bas qui a
vraiment resserré aux professionnels ajp
il n'y a aucun profil type je dirais il
ya des jeunes ya des moins jeunes
alors donc moi si demain j'ai un
problème de robinetterie par exemple et
que je cherche quelqu'un pour me
dépanner je peux venir à l'association
cotisé m'inscrire et éventuellement
faire part de mes compétences pour aider
aussi les autres oui tout à fait mais en
général il ne faut pas venir avec mes
idées préconçues c'est à dire il faut
pas venir avec l'idée qu'on va trouver
spécifiquement
par exemple un plombier etc parce qu on
pourra être déçu on n'est pas certain de
retrouver dans la dans l'association ce
type 2 non il faut venir à être ouvert
avec l'esprit de partager et c'est au
fil du temps que contrôlent les
personnes les bonnes personnes et qui
peuvent vous aider entendu et bien en
tout cas merci beaucoup pour laisser
renseignements grâce à vous on en sait
un peu plus sur la fonction d'appel
merci beaucoup je vous en prie nous
allons désormais voir un cas concret des
changes entre deux adhérents c'est dans
son appartement que lalita adhérents du
sel à guyancourt depuis trois ans reçoit
lille est inscrite elle depuis un an et
demi les deux adhérentes ont l'habitude
d'échanger des services
la spécialité de lalita les massages est
ce que tu préfères aujourd'hui jasmin
comme d'habitude ou à monde sinon là
j'ai cette fois ci largo
qu'est ce que tu veux le bon ça va
sentir au sel de guyancourt chacun
possède des inscriptions 75 points ici
les euros sont bannis et sont remplacés
par des grenouilles
par exemple quelqu'un qui a besoin qu'on
convient de jardiner chez lui et on
demande de l'aide on met une annonce et
en fonction de la personne qui dit oui
j'accepte de vous couper
j'ai pas de tailler la haie par exemple
pour deux heures en échange vous me
donner ses comptes grenouille si on est
d'accord on négocie le nombre de points
si on est d'accord on excepte à ce
moment là la personne qui a un jardin
qui avait besoin de cette aide donne ce
conte grenouille à l'autre personne
les adhérents du sel peuvent aussi
échanger en fonction de leur
savoir-faire sans amputer leur nombre de
points lisait à garder la fille de
lalita durant plusieurs jours après
l'école
le massage ne lui coûtera donc aucune
grenouille ce soit comme on vit dans une
société de consommation - ce qui m'a
vraiment attiré dans un premier temps
c'était voilà tout est recyclé la table
qui parti qui voulaient partir à la
poubelle j'allais récupérer et puis le
la bibliothèque et puis voilà donc on ne
gaspille rien quand je dis par exemple
dans ma famille un petit yacht à une
nouvelle robe gm à côté une grenouille
le concept séduit de plus en plus par
ces temps de crise les yvelines compte
actuellement 900 l'éco-consommation
c'est aussi envisager nos déplacements
différemment la casse qui a lancé un
service de covoiturage en 2007 nous
sommes précisément dans les locaux de la
direction des transports de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec vous
maylis fourier bon jour en jour comment
fonctionne ce système de covoiturage le
système de covoiturage et fonctionnent
le plus simplement possible parce qu'en
fait c'est une plateforme de mise en
relation de gens qui veulent covoiturer
et de gens qui recherchent un véhicule
pour faire le déplacement
alors moi si je veux voilà rendre
service j'ai une voiture je veux
proposer mon itinéraire pour pour voilà
prendre des gens avec moi dans mon
véhicule je m'inscris sur cette
plateforme comment ça se passe alors je
vais sur la plateforme
l avantage de cette plate forme c'est en
fait qu'on peut regarder les trajets qui
nous intéresse et si il y a les trajets
qui nous intéresse on peut s'inscrire et
adhérer à la plateforme de covoiturage
ce qui nous permettra ensuite d'être mis
en relation avec les gens qui propose
des trajets il y à une cotisation c'est
gratuit le site de covoiturage et
gratuit après ce qui se passe c'est que
pour le paiement de l'usaj du
covoiturage il ya deux solutions pour
les usagers si par exemple ils font du
covoiturage dans le cadre du domicile
travail
en fait c'est par exemple chacun reprend
sa voiture un jour sur deux donc dans ce
cas il n'y a pas d' échanges financiers
parce que c'est un jour sur deux par
contre si toujours la même personne qui
prend le véhicule ou qui proposent enfin
les rôles sont différenciées dans ce cas
là il ya une tarification qui est
possible et qui peut se faire par le
biais de la plateforme est par contre
sûr sur cette tarification il ya un
pourcentage qui est pris par la
plateforme de covoiturage.fr mais
davantage en fait c'est que ça permet de
sécuriser en fait les usagers parce
qu'ils passent par la plate forme et
nous n'y a pas d'échangé financier au
moment du déplacement il se fait après
par le biais de la plateforme
donc ça sécurise beaucoup d'usagers ça
les incite en fait à faire du
covoiturage un cassoulet les bénéfices
quand on fait du covoiturage le bénéfice
le plus direct c'est une question
financière c'est le coup en fait
ce que montrent les études sur le
covoiturage c'est que quelqu'un qui fait
du covoiturage tous les jours pour du
domicile de travail pour un déplacement
de 20 km en moyenne
il va économiser 2002 1100 euros par an
donc c'est un avantage financier en
premier lieu ça permet de réduire la
congestion
ce qui est important pour la
collectivité est également de réduire
l'impact environnemental de la voiture
donc c'est vraiment ces deux avantages
pour la collectivité
est ce qu'il y a des désavantages des
inconvénients à faire de covoiturage la
difficulté de la promotion du
covoiturage c'est que aujourd'hui dans
les déplacements les déplacements sont
de plus en plus complexes et les gens
ont pris l'habitude ben on va au travail
peu après on fait un saut à la salle de
gym on récupère des enfants on va faire
les courses
donc par rapport à cette complexité des
déplacements le covoiturage ne trouve
pas forcément sa place pour les
déplacements de tous les jours par
contre on peut imaginer qu'un jour ou
deux on peut faire du covoiturage et en
fait ça permet déjà de réduire de 20 à
30% sont enfin le coût économique des
transports et l'impact environnemental
des transports donc c'est une solution
qui permette complété après les
pratiques de déplacements vous n'existez
pas peut-être pas faire du covoiturage
tous les jours mais peut-être un ou deux
jours par semaine et après engendrait
des nouvelles pratiques rien merci
beaucoup pour tout ces renseignements
sur ce service de la casse qui le
covoiturage comment ça se passe voici un
cas bien concret avec deux adhérents
d'itinéraires partager 18h heure de
sortie des bureaux et aux heures de
pointe sur les routes
sylvie massucci assistante travaux chez
bouygues construction à guyancourt se
dirige vers le parking de l'entreprise
direction les places réservées au
covoiturage depuis la mi janvier sylvie
a décidé qu'elle ne voyagerait plus seul
dans son véhicule
en premier lieu pour une question
cruciale par ces temps de crise le côté
financier essentiellement ensuite on
voit là
le fait de pas faire le trajet tout seul
c'est 60 km c'est quand même
seul c'est quand même assez long donc
c'est quand même assez agréable de
pouvoir discuter avec les gens et non ça
se passe bien mais c'est surtout le côté
financier au départ guyancourt dreux 67
km le quotidien de celles vie au sein de
son entreprise elle a trouvé trois
autres collègues qui pratiquent le
covoiturage depuis septembre 2012 sylvie
potier également employé chez bout de
construction fait partie de l'équipe
dans l'emploi du temps de chacune s'il
faut s'adapter par rapport à une absence
des congés ont fait des échanges mais en
règle générale c'est une semaine chacune
à l'instar de bouygues construction
d'autres entreprises de l'agglomération
encourage le covoiturage c'est le cas du
groupe malakoff médéric
ici aussi les emplacements sont réservés
pour les covoitureurs
mais le concept peine malgré tout a
démarré c'est vraiment un état d'esprit
une question de mentalité les gens ont
du mal à s'accaparer l'idée qu'on peut
co voiturer qu'on peut voyager à deux ou
à trois ses parents cran rentrer dans
nos moeurs mais faut pas désespérer la
preuve nos deux sylvie ne renonceraient
au covoiturage pour rien au monde
ainsi s'achève ce nouveau numéro d'
équilibre qui fera peut-être de vous les
éco consommateurs de demain
avant de nous quitter quelques dates à
noter dans vos agendas
l'éco consommation il en sera question
justement à la maison de l'environnement
le samedi 26 janvier autour du thème
quel écho consommateurs est de vous
l'occasion de rencontrer les acteurs du
sel de rambouillet et puis pour être éco
consommateur jusqu'au bout la maison de
l'environnement propose des ateliers les
mercredis 6 et samedi 9 février pour
apprendre à fabriquer soi-même savon et
dentifrice nous on se retrouve le 15
février
très bonne année à toutes et à tous ciao